we learn best when we're learning from
content that we find interesting
comprehensible input or as stephen
krashen renowned expert on language
language acquisition calls it compelling
content so make sure you choose material
choose lessons that interest you you may
find them on your feed these could be
lessons that other people at link are
studying it could be
newspaper articles that are
regularly
presented to you on your feed you may
even want to import and you should
familiarize yourself with the different
ways of importing lessons we have a and
chrome extension and a google extension
whereby you can and also a firefox
extension so that you can import
anything you find on the web this is
also available on your tablet
uh make sure you're familiar you
familiarize yourself you can also import
ebooks
into link and if you're smart find the
audio book for it so make sure you
are fully aware of how to bring
interesting content into your learning
space it's going to help your learning